the emotions are running high for
brandon woodruff as he takes the mound
knowing what's in front of him the next
couple of days so hopefully you can keep
those emotions under control and put
together a quality start here for the
brewers before heading home two balls
two strikes to eric gonzalez and a swing
and a miss on a fastball from woodruff
and that's how this sunday afternoon
begins
and a liner
snagged by urias and that'll do it for
the pirates so that's four straight
starts now for woodruff without allowing
a hit in the first and stephen brault
will take the mountain for the buckos
this afternoon now hopefully stephen
will have that good command good control
and the pitch
and the late swing of the miss on a
fastball and he strikes out urias to
start one away
good call john as he strikes out casting
hira
and the brewers strand a couple
gregory polanco will lead it off
that ball's hammered toward right center
field by gregory polanco and
we're gonna have some coffee today as
gregory polanco el cafe hits his fifth
and gives the pirates a one-nothing lead
and that snaps his hitless string
in a big way
over his last 18 before that long ball
and again the 2-2
got him fastball swung out and missed
for the first out of the inning
and that is straight three called he'll
get the inside edge so three strikeouts
through the first two for brandon
woodruff but a homer from polanco has
the pirates first on the board
that's a good pitch struck him out
looking third k
[Applause]
in the dirt and taking off for second
base and he's going to get him
and as they always do they say no no no
no he didn't get me i think he wants a
dugout to take a look here
i think he misses him i think he's safe
and i think he kept he kept the bag
there too
keep thinking he's ready to take off the
headset here we are stay safe
thank you
arcia gets second
[Music]
and he ends up getting him
[Applause]
there you go backwards k
he'll get his share of those back to
back in fact got murphy to win the
second gets martin to start the third
swing at a miss
fastball gets frazier and for the first
time today woodruff puts him down in
order
let's hit sharply and right through josh
bell and yellets will reach
nice
not a backdoor slider a back foot slider
and that's big out see if hira can run
into one here and this is into center
field that's going to drop and that's
plenty good enough for the brewers to
get their first run
as ureas is in from third rbi single
from here and we are tied at one
that's a solid single
and that gets him off
the schneid uh oh for 20 against the
brewers this season before that line
single to center to start the fourth for
kevin newman
and now josh bell
homered yesterday
53 pitches and this one is launched
josh bell ring your bell with a bomb
i mean he drove that one out
for his fourth
he certainly didn't miss that one
and the pirates regain the lead it's 3-1
here's the 1-2
got him swinging fastball right on the
edge 1-q
home run strikeout it's kind of the way
the game is these days
fastball from woodruff
strikeout number seven back to back here
in the fourth
and the three two from woodruff
outside ball four he's walked another
very rare back-to-back walks for brenda
woodruff
and a line drive by newman that's going
to drop in for a hit
and the pirates
pick up another run but
hopefully out at third yeah did gonzalez
score
this is being reviewed
wow
yeah that's a you can't make that base
running mistake there i mean it plays
right in front of you
you have two outs there's really no
advantage to you being on third base
there the ruling on the field was that
run did score and
he does score
so the pirates do take
a 4-1 lead
[Applause]
another funky delivery from down under
and a safe call at first base an infield
a hit for gonzalez
frazier oh for one with a pair of walks
and that's smacked into right field
runner going to be waived and the throw
to the plate is going to be late
as jason martin scores adam frazier
the rbi single makes it a 5-1 game
and that got here i think yes it did so
back to back hit batters
and the brewers are going to bring the
tying run to the plate and it's going to
be a pinch hitter they're going to be
calling they're going to call back
mathias and it's two and two on justin
smoke
and he struck him out there swinging on
a slider and justice is served so harley
comes on and strands two and we're
through seven from miller park it's 5-1
pirates
richard rodriguez
is on to work the
ninth inning for the pirates
this ball hit well
martin
a beat on it and makes the catch raise
the jolly roger the pirates down the
brewers in milwaukee game three of this
four game series